So, the ANTS toolkit, ANTS stands for
Active Node Transfer System, took a different
approach to show the utility of the
vision. Since modifying the protocol stack is nontrivial,
instead, the ANTS toolkit is really an
application-level package. And this toolkit is available for
the application programmer to say, here is
my pay load and quality of service constraints.
And what the ANTS toolkit does is to create
an ANTS header to this payload. So, the new payload
looks like this. And this is what is called a
capsule. And a capsule consists of an ANTS header and
the actual payload. And this is what is given
to a normal operation system protocol stack. And so, this
normal operating system protocol stack looks at this as the
payload that has been given to it and it knows
the destination address, where this has to go sticks on
the IP header for it. So, the new packet that
is generated by the protocol stack, looks like this. It
has the IP header, and the rest is payload so
long as This protocol stack is concerned, but we know
this payload consists of two parts. One is the normal
payload that the application generated, and in addition to that
there is the ANTS header that have been slapped on by
the ANTS tool kit and this is what traverses the
network and when it traverses the network if a node in
the network is a normal node, meaning it is not a
smart node, but it is a normal IP router. Then it
simply uses the IP header to say, well, here is
what I have to do in terms of sending the packet
to the next hop, towards the destination. On the other hand,
if a node that receives this packet is an active node.
Then, it can actually process this ANTS header, and
say, oh, this particular packet needs to be. Demuliplexed, and
sent to two different routes. And it might take that
intelligent routing decision based on the nature of that node.
So that's the idea, that we can push one
of the paint points out of the operating system, into
an enhanced toolkit that lives above the operating system. So
that's sort of the ANTS toolkit vision. That's one part.
Now, the second part, and of course the fact
that the internet may not be open to opening
up all of the routers to to be processing
the specialized code that comes in the capsule. So, what
we do is we keep the active nodes only
at the edge of the network. In other words,
the core IP network is unchanged, and all of
the magic happens only at the edge of the network.
So, once again, if I go back to my
example of sending greetings to my siblings, then only the
edge nodes have to do the magic in order to
take my original message and process the code to deliver
it to multiple destinations. So the rest of the network
can remain unchanged. So the core of the IP network
can, can be unchanged, and intelligence can be at the
edge of the network. So this is, sort of, allowing,
sort of, matting this active network vision
with the core IP network being unchanged.